[Musique]
alors c'est dire que la côte je lai a
serré les rangs pour ne pas dire
continuellement qui est une forme de
priapisme mais c'est un prix alice
télévisuelle donc je l' ai évidemment
une promenade sur la plage de dunkerque
avec une dame qui imite à la perfection
de prix la wet et qui donc réussi à
attirer les boîtes à elle et je rêvais
depuis longtemps de rencontrer des
mouettes
grâce à cette femme j'ai dit plus rien
de ces brèves alors il y avait les
corons la terre c'est l horizon non pas
dans l'immédiat non pas dans l'immédiat
parce que j'ai beaucoup plaisir
justement être sorti des studios et à
retourner sur le terrain pour aller
tourner des reportages
[Musique]
grande liberté en faisant ça et j'aime
bien l'idée d'aller au devant des gens
d'aller à leur rencontre
non prenant pas dans l'immédiat non si
je vais travailler qu'un chroniqueur
isabelle morini-bosc je pense c'est de
construire autour concluante et jours